conservatives for a long time we've just
been so nice and I still think we should
be just and do the right thing and
virtuous but we got to be a little less
nice okay I think we need to start
wielding power a little bit more I think
we've got to engage in lawfare people
always think that the threshold for
defamation suits is too high because of
the ridiculous standards set by New York
Times versus Sullivan one that decision
should have been overturned it's
ridiculous it should be much easier to
sue people for intentionally lying about
you but but two
you can see now when conservatives push
back at all and when we've got a little
power and money behind us people cave
Rolling Stone caved Daily Beast caved
when they defamed me after the CPAC
speech and we're going to sick the same
kind of lawyers on the people that went
after men